notre ami Fran tapirou cette vidéo
virale on reviendra dessus
dans alors il y a Audrey qui va nous
rejoindre la première dauphine qui était
la favorite du public elle est arrivée
première du public et on va revenir
maintenant heure par heure sur Miss
France et audre va venir nous rejoindre
autant vous dire que on va passer des
bons moments à 20h22 en direct dans
TPMP déjà je voudrais dire pour moi
Jean-Pierre fou a été vraiment c'est le
Toer je t'embrasse mon Jean-Pierre merci
pour voilà d'être toujours auprès de moi
et d'être toujours aussi fidèle à côté
je sais que je toujours fidèle aussi et
vraiment c'est pas parce que tu es mon
pote vraiment on voit que c'est l'uter
Jean je suis désolé il a été
exceptionnel toute la soirée vraiment il
a été très bon et c'est vrai que c'est
le patron il y a que lui qui peut faire
ça aujourd'hui animateur emblématique
des Miss France depuis 95 il a encore
fait une entrée remarquée puisqu'il est
arrivé en pyjama Jean-Pierre fou et je
l'ai vu en replay ça j'avais pas vu au
début
regarde ah quel bonheur de pouvoir enfin
regarder l'émission tranquille à la
maison j'aimerais bien savoir quiils ont
trouvé comme petit jeune pour remplacer
l'ancien oh là là je peux pas être
tranquille 2 secondes
c'estance Jean-Pierre on t'attend sur le
plateau le plateau quel plateau
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
histoire
[Musique]
j alors on vaevenir sur tous les
tableaux bien sûr de la soirée et on est
très heureux d'accueillir Audrey merci
d'être là Audrey bonsoir franchement je
je t'ai trouvé exceptionnel j'ai revu
l'émission je te le dis et je t'ai
trouvé exceptionnel dans ton discours
franchement je te jure que tu vas faire
de la télé toi j'ai trouvé une fluidité
cétait la plus fluide je trouve tu étais
la plus naturelle au niveau des discours
on va en parler dans un instant mais et
d'ailleurs tu étais la favorite du
public alors moi j'aiaimé beaucoup aussi
Eve je te le dis parce que je trouve
qu'elle a amené aussi un truc et et et
je vais te demander quelque chose vous
êtes resté très longtemps comme ça vous
tenir la main toutes les deux à attendre
et vous arrêtiz pas de vous parler vous
disiez quoi c'est toi c'est toi alors tu
as pas faim alors non ben non en fait on
essayie de de détendre l'atmosphère
parce que c'est vrai que c'est des c'est
des minutes assez stressant qu'est-ce
que tu dis est-ce que tu dis je vais
gagner ou pas alors non enfin à ce
moment-là j'étais on voulait tuer de la
couronne hein vraiment on était là pour
ça on a travaillé dur pour ça mais c'est
vrai que c'est un cou Miss France et
malheureusement il doit y avoir qu'une
seule Miss une seule gagnante et c'est
Eve qui a eu la couronne et je suis très
fière d'elle et donc à ce moment-là on
parlait de de de nos ressentis et puis
moi je disais ce que ce que je pensais
d'Ève donc au cours de cette aventure
comment je la voyais que c'était une
belle personne avec un bon frond vous
vous étiez bien entendu oui oui oui
vraiment ouais ça s'est très bien passé
et puis je lui ai dit que quoi qu'il
quoi tu pensais que gagné ou pas quand
quand on est plus que deux parce que
c'est vrai que mais oui bah bien sûr que
oui je croyais en moi c'est c'est normal
c'est logique bon tu es contente quand
même ou pas bah oui bien sûr jeis
première pr mais c'est vrai c'est pas
rien nous on n été jamais été premier
dauphine de
rien t je te dis on n jamais été
première dauphine de rien du tout donc
je te le dis non mais franchement mais
en tout cas merci tu vas on va on va
débriefer avec toi la soirée et trend ça
te fait quelque chose quand même d'avoir
été parce que tu es quand même tu es la
mise France du public parce que tu
arrivé en tête je com
non mais je remercie le le public parce
que vraiment j'ai j'ai été choquée quand
je suis rentrée euh euh le soir waouh de
de voir que toute la France en fait
m'acclamait ou autre parce que c'est
vrai que je suis Miss Guan ça reste
autour de la Guyane et je savais pas que
toute la France par allit être derrière
moi et j'étais vraiment ravie j'étais
trop contente parce que j'ai beaucoup
bossé pour en arriver là et le travail
paye vraiment c'est tu fais quoi dans la
vie alors moi je suis actuellement en
première année de preppa Business School
pour rentrer en école de commerce savoir
que j'ai 18 ans 18 ans pour ça discours
à 18 ans ouais non c'est pour ça je me
suis dit à 18 ans j'ai eu mon bac il y a
a 3 mois ah ouais c'est vrai bah nous on
l' jamais
eu tu vois non mais c'est vrai qu'elle a
eu son bac rendez compte elle a que 18
ans et franchement tu as une assurance
tu avais une assurance samedi soir bravo
à toi alors les Miss ont ouvert la
cérémonie avec un show à l'américaine
alors qu'on était aux Zénit de Dijon
c'est ça qui est bien regardez cétait
sur du
[Applaudissements]
billon
us
no so CRA
[Applaudissements]
now
you
ah cétait sympa et alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de la soirée moi j'ai
adoré la soirée fort je suis content du
choix de la miss je trouve que vous
auriez pu être aussi Miss franchement
les deux étaient top j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait du rythme et effectivement j'ai
trouv que Jean-Pierre foucot depuis la
première scène que vous avez montré avec
le pyjama jusqu'à la fin je trouve qu'il
a porté la soirée de bout en bout
c'était moins brillant à ses côtés j'ai
trouvé Cindy Fab un peu plus discrè mais
lui oui elle est gentille mais je trouve
que lui a été normal lui c'est son
métieré n Il il a été magistral voilà
j'ai aimé j'ai aimé les chorégraphies
aussi je trouve que c'était super
travaillé et très moderne c'est beaucoup
de travail ché ou pas alors oui on était
parce que c'est pas relou si on est pas
sélectionné dans les 15 on a pris les
chorégraphies quand même en fait oui
alors on apprend donc toutes les les 30
points du on apprend les chorégraphies
du coup du premier au dernier tableau
ouais ou et donc à part les tableaux des
10 on sait qui est enfin il y a parce
qu'il y avait le tableau rock années 80
et ça ça donc là on apprend no tableau
spécifique mais sinon on apprend tous
les tableaux 15 on pas dans les 15 c'est
hyper relou ça veut dire que toute la
partie moi je leur dis la vérité je leur
dis vous me dites tout de suite je suis
dans les 15 mais après c'est aussi un
plaisir he parce que faut bosser mais
faut avoir envie d'être là parce que
c'est quand même 8h de répétition par
jour c'est un rythme qui est int temp si
on n pas envie ça se voit tout de suite
av tu avais été forte au au test de
culture générale alors ça s'est bien
passé mais c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué he le test je sais pas si vous
l'avez fait ah mais il était dur parce
que nous encore cétait des questions
ouvertes vous vous avez eu un petit QCM
c'est des questions
ouvertes la première fois qu'ils ont
fait un test s QCM c'était dur c'était
chaud alors à 22h30 on a eu le fameux
défilet en maillot de bain sur le thème
des années 30 c'était un maillot une
pièce comme le veut la tradition des
Miss France
[Applaudissements]
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
let
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
girl audre prierhine de France qui éta
avec nous oui qui qui qui a regardé tout
le monde j'ai regardé j'ai comparé ça au
super ball on a notre super ball de la
beauté j'ai trouvé ça super et c'est
vrai qu'on voit que justement Alexa la
Roubert a quand même mis un peps à
l'américen et bravo à elle vraiment
merci VO c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit
c'est la seule
émission qu'on regarde sele émission où
j'avais des gens samedi soir je leur dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais ce soir ce
soirutour de la télé pour regarder c'est
la seule émission dont tu peux parler le
lendemain avec tes potes des pronos puis
surtout c'est une émission qui a
plusieurs grilles de lecture parce que
si tu le regardes avec ta grand-mère
très prier de regarder avec des copains
être un peu plus dans dans la rigolade
tu peux regarder avec les petits enfants
donc il y a plein de grill de lecture si
tu as envie mais chacun il trouve son
compte je dis regardez-moi les mage de
mes potes on en pense quoi de la
nouvelle Miss France mon
frèrere les réponses je pense qu'il faut
que je me penche sur le profil de Miss
Provence sur début 2024 qui va m'envoyer
ça non mais c'est s rigolé non je vous
dis donc c'est tout le monde en parle en
fait c'est et là où c'est très fort
c'est que c'est très commenté sur les
réseaux aussi donc ils ont réussi à
convertir ça je luis demandé parce que
les gens sont très très durs sur les
réseau parfois avec est-ce que vous
l'avez mal pris vous personnellement de
pouvoir lire des trucs pas très sympa
alors non moi j'ai eu quand même un
retour assez positif sur les réseaux
sociaux mais c'est vrai que pour
c'est horrible et je ben je profite du
coup de ce passage sur TPMP pour
demander aux personnes d'arrêter parce
que si c'était vous je pense que vous
auriez vraiment pas aimé être insulté
mais elle essaie de franchement je vais
pas parler
demain mais voilà donc en plus elle
vient demain donc pourra lui poser la
question mais franchement c'est c'est
c'est je pense que c'est pas nécessaire
tout ce harcèlement comme une
excuse- excuse-moi
mais c'estra non maisain une trentaine
de Miss on fait un hommage aussi à je de
fon qui est décédé cette année cet été à
l'âge de de 90 ans 17 ans 90 ans hommage
très émouvant avec j'ai et j'ai vu en
regardant ça j'avais pas je savais pas
que Valérie Pascal elle était Miss le
Ting sur sur enfin le M6 Boutique je
savais vous l'avez su mais vous l'avez
oublié peut-être non je savais pas je
l'ai vu j'ai MOS médiiatis j'ai dis mais
c'est elle c'est pas
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde quand même quelque chose de
solide Miss
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il y avait pas il manquait
maliamenard iris mener et camissire pour
des raisons personnelles voilà vousz ou
pas sur ce sur sur cet hommage après
c'était beau mais malgré tout elle a été
quand même exfiltrée de la de la
cérémonie pendant des années c'était un
peu la personn grat ouais mais c'est
normal normal mais à la passé auelà de
ça pas fa norm mais ça prouve que ça
reste l'une des Figur incontournable de
ce concours parce que au dépend des des
conflits qu'elle avait pu avoir avec
Sylvie Tellier par le passé ouais
oui je l'adore ran je sais pas il il
s'est chauffé ouais non mais tuas raison
raison j'aime bien parce qu' elle trouve
toujours des problèmes elle oui c'est
vrai ça arrête Géraldine c'est vrai ça
ou faut retenir le positif on rend
hommage à une grande dame et puis c'est
son institution finalement oui mais une
institution que malgré tout qu'il a
maltraité à un moment donné aussi mal
traité mais qui finalement reconnait ses
erreurs aujourd'hui voilà exactement il
a raison tué obligé de lui rendre homage
mais évidemment s surtout que moi paremp
j'ai regardé cette émission avec un
couple d'amis au début on rigolait on
est tombé sur cette séquence et ben ça
nous a cloué le bec parce que moi je
l'ai trouvé magnifique cette séquence en
plus c'était intéressant c'était
émouvant et et c'est vrai qu'après on
peut penser un petit peu comme
geréraldine et se dire oui est-ce que
c'est pas un peu hypocrite mais quand tu
vois les miss c'est pas elle qui décide
de de ce qui se passe en interne dans le
concours donc on peut se dire quand même
qu'elles sont honnêtes quand elles
versent la
larmun sou bien sûr plus tard dans la
soirée avec les 15 Miss restantes donc
tu tu été Audrey tu as fait le deuxième
défilé en maillot de bain deux pièces
cette fois sur le thème du flamenco tu
sais que tu es un grand champion de
[Rires]
F découvre il avit que 4 ans en
andalousiei tui donnes des bottines des
castagnettes
uno
Pen
[Musique]
Pia si tienes
ganasorar Pia
[Musique]
meso
alors y en a qui ont été déçu par ce
shorty ils ont dit ouais c'est considéré
comme un maillot de bain de pièces ça je
comprends pas tout ça vous comprenez les
rageux sur les
Réau je pardon mais je l'ai dit devant
ma télé je suis obligé de le dire parce
on est honnête sur ce PL ah ouais bah je
me suis dit non c'est pas un maillot de
bain c'est du vu lourd c'est pas la
bonne matière la coupe bah c'est un
manche longue enfin je j'ai pas vu le
rapport ouais j'étais déçu mais par
contre la tenue était
magnifique à la tenue des réions par
exle ma sœ qui m'écrit je vous jure
c'est vrai je kiffe Kelly ma sœur tu es
bien la seule dans la famille merci je
rigole ça va je c'est VO ça donc elle
nous regarde ma sœur qui nous regarde
pas souvent en plus voilà donc à mon
avis elle a dû se tromper deux personnes
fait un bisou qui à votre sœur V s ah
bah c'estembrasse tout le temps ouis
c'est bon mais arrête de m'envoyer des
conneries
parecrei sur ton
travailme quand même ton petit
frère c'est votre sœur soyez gentille
oui mais j'ai toujours été le le grand
frère même si je suis plus petit qu'elle
7 ans tu vois calme-toi va travail
va il a fallu attendre presque 1 heure
du matin pour qu' g soit couronné devant
6,14 million de téléspectateurs à la fin
il y a eu ouais regardez Miss France
2024 et et
restera Miss
norpatcalet et la première de F est Miss
[Applaudissements]
guyan
Audrey ça te fait quoi quand tu vois ça
Audrey j'ai envie de pleurer non c'est
vrai mais pleure on s'en fout y en a
plein qui on pleurer les cam qui pleure
pas ici c'est loui Boyard quand il VI
non non tu il a pleuré face à moi ouais
c'est vrai face à toi non mais c'est
vrai ça est-ce que tu as des est-ce que
tu pleures parce que tu dis franchement
je suis passé à ça ou bien parce que
c'est un moment non ça restera un moment
magique pour toi tout c'est un moment
magique d'être arrivé jusqu'à là
franchement je ouais tu pens tu pensais
ou pas oui bah oui j'ai mais de le
réaliser c'est différent c'est de on dit
quoi ta famille tes parents et tout ah
il était tellement fier de moi vraiment
de pouvoir porter la guyan jusqu'à ce
titre et de de pouvoir montrer une autre
image du coup de de mon territoire non
franchement il était très Fiè de moi
très fi du parcours que j'ai accompli à
mon âge ils avaient peur au début parce
que j'étais jeune bien sû mais euh en
tout cas tu as l'air très mature ouais
c'est vrai ça va être quoi maintenant le
programme pour la première dupine c'est
quoi le programme alors donc c'est ma
c'est ma délégation donc le comité
misgun qui s'occupe de moi donc j'ai
j'ai quelques sollicitations ben comme
avec po puis bon je le glisse par ici
mais j'aimerais bien faire danser avec
les stars voilà pas moi c'est pas Mo sa
pas oui je sais je sais mais voilà parce
que j'aime beaucoup danser j'aime
beaucoup la scène et
tout c'est une bonne idée tu veux pas
faire parce que moi je veux pas faire
colanta j'ai dis là tu peux faire les
Marseillais pas faire Jordan de luxe tu
pasux faire Jordane dexe je peuxir
Jordan mais c'est pas mal Jordan d'
faudrait qu'elle le fasse tuas tu vas
chialer là-bas ceux qui vont il chi tous
ceux qui vont là-bas il chialent ils
disent du bien de moi tu vas
kiffer oui j'ai j'ai encore du débrief
mais allez non je juste une petite
question comme ça dans tous les groupes
de de filles généralement il y a deux
trois pces qu'on déteste est-ce que il y
en avait parmi vous alors là tu es
magnifique voilà je te oh
mer
ça donc sin on s'entendait tout peti
info croustillante non franchement on
s'entendait toutes bien avec les filles
c'est vrai que j'ai plus d'affinité avec
avec Miss Guadeloupe en les miss
d'outrem et tout parce qu'on a un petit
peu le même la même VIB mais c'est
personne s'est démarqué celle-ci non
franchement non bon ça c'est très bien
par c'était pas une promo de Pest non on
enlève les clichés sur les miss Pest
euh vous aviez comme favorite Miss Nord
pcalé euh alors au départ non j'ai mais
moi j'aimais carlachir mais j'avais dit
évidemment qu'on
pasal
Miss justement vair j'ai quand même dit
que voilà elle avait vraiment un truc un
peu très moderne à la Linda Evangelista
à l'époque et je trou que c'était
vraiment intéressant alors on va revenir
sur les rigolades aussi de ce concours
Miss France qui ont le fait fait le plus
parler sur sur X il y avait des trucs
pas mal on va commencer avec Miss Pays
de la
Loire on va revenir là-dessus dans un
instant vous reste avec nous et puis
dans un instant on reviendra aussi sur
cette vidéo virale ou Franck tapir vous
connaissez bien
euh croyait le
connaître c'est relou les gars non mais
on va revenir cette vidéo virale qui a
fait énormément parler Fran sera avec
nous dans un instant en direct BMP à
tout de suite tu restes avec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous